the Chancellor's Autumn Statement this
Wednesday is expected to be pretty low
on giveaways some query whether the
economic cost of brexit means the UK
economy is in for a tough run no matter
what Philip Hammond the Chancellor
announces well Labour MP chuka Romana is
a former shadow business secretary and a
supporter of the open britain campaign
conservative Dominic rub is member of
the exiting the EU committee and was a
leave campaigner of course send a very
good morning to you both gentlemen I'm
sure you've got different views on what
miss Talmadge should do and I want to
start with you Dominic Robin it's that
basic point do you recognise this figure
of a hundred billion pounds that the obr
is going to tell us that the Treasury is
going to have to borrow extra over the
next five years we don't know what the
API is going to say what we do know
would you recognize a large figure I
don't know I don't know but the
forecasts have all been proved wrong so
far the IMF the Bank of England and the
official statistics have all gone back
on those forecasts so let's wait and see
what we know hard core hard developments
in the economy last week alone
employment at record highs inflation
dipping below 1% notwithstanding the
devaluation of sterling at Google the
latest company to announce a billion
pounds of extra vestment so let's not
have this endless pessimism actually the
headline is from all of this the
employee the Chancellor's just well idly
endless peasants in the Chancellor's
just been talking about an eye-watering
lee large debt well no I think those are
words that have been put in national
debt terms yes of course because until
we've got the boring adds to the desk
but until we've got the deficit down
we've always known we've had this debate
for since to 2010 we're not going to
really get to grips with national debt
so he's right and I support him being a
fiscal hawk but the economic resilience
of the economy post breaks it has Frank
nor I found it that point peasant that
point chuga Ramallah this this hundred
billion that's been floated around the
cost over five years might be wrong
since Dominic Rock well I mean he's
right in the sense of these being
forecasts but on the Treasury's own
forecast we know that they think that if
for example we were to come out of the
EU customs union and end up trading with
the EU and the rest of the world on WTO
rules we would be looking at at least a
sixty six billion pound hit per year
what comes into this Jack and I have
just quoted a big number but that's far
bigger than say what we spend on
education but look where'd you get what
well the priority here in this Autumn
Statement is to ensure that if you work
hard you play by the rules you do the
right thing whatever your background you
and your family see the rewards now even
before we voted to leave the European
Union Hardware this was not happening in
the last conservative-led coalition it's
certainly not happening in this
Parliament now the question is does
brexit make it more or less easy to
resolve that issue I would argue now you
can see that it makes it less ok and I
give you a reason very tangible reason
why if you look at the deep depreciation
in sterling it means that the things
that we import costing a lot more so
your viewers and they're going to buy
things in the shop imported goods they
are paying more for that to come through
any no so I mean on the hard figures
which is what I'm looking for that's
come through in the balance of payments
figures hasn't it the first that's right
well we since brexit not much Jay
Boileau hang on just a minute
since the last Autumn Statement
depreciation of Sterling's depreciated
by around 21% but they're really big
full particularly after we left the
Europe we voted to leave the European
Union came around October because of
uncertainty about the way in which we're
going to be able to trade with the rest
of the world so that's a very tangible
way in which actually the uncertainty
coming from the brexit vote is impacting
on your group I have to say that the my
biggest issue what is tradition it's
have a debate got yeah let go you got to
tell me what you're trying another time
this is what I'm looking for yeah what's
wrong it's a big numbers around but this
on the Business Survey CBR last week
thousand businesses 65 billion pounds of
investment on hold
that's what businesses have said what
first of all by the way in terms of the
record of the government nearly three
million new jobs since 2010 and three
million taken of the lowest paid workers
taken out of income tax I think that's a
pretty good record to build on and but
actually in terms of inflation there is
a risk here because of the devaluation
of sterling but what we just seen last
week inflation dipping below 1% so let's
not these forecasts it would go through
the roof have certainly not materialized
on the facts yet in terms of the city
and business confidence at Chevron it's
remarkable hearing both caralyn fair
behen
head of the CBI and John Longworth
former head of the British Chamber of
Commerce on the BBC today both talking
about the opportunities of brexit
particularly around trade and I think
there's a huge amount of evidence what
do you accept I mean there are plenty of
people on the leave side who do say this
look there might be a short term but in
the long run it'll be worth it I mean
would you endorse those comments there
is definitely some short-term reason
some uncertainty and of course until
businesses see at least the contours of
the negotiation some decisions are on
hold but let's not turn that into a
boundless democracy then a Chosen they
knew that it might take this is ridic
there's a long range this is this is
ridiculous that the reason why the
forecast and the data are not as bad as
people thought they would be back in
August is because of the aggressive
monetary policy measures at the Bank of
England the governor introduced
increasing quantitative easing
reducing interest rates and what
happened to the governor as a result of
that he had come through his head calls
for his resignation now the question is
one of mobile elite what should well
what should Philip Hammond do on
Wednesday first of all we should make
good on the promise that many of those
who campaign for us to leave gave to the
country in your viewers but if we left
the European Union we'd be put on a path
to putting 350 million pounds extra per
week into our NHS so that's one thing
secondly yes it was wrong second by the
second we made very clear well before
the referees we did buy the hammer pain
is where you also this is a problem
Oates this is you're siphoning $300
million into the English record of the
old debate let's move forward I'd love
to work with Washington he was wave of
them nothing more money should be put
into more money to go in the NHS a new
campaign for that but we said 150
million out of it when we were pressed
oh seven of them 15 oh yeah we talked
about that was one three three nobody on
the book thing that should happen about
that Wednesday 300
I said look as a campaign we think this
is the kind of thing we could do with
the money we'll get back but of course
it's for the electric government inside
I still stand by that but what we really
ought to be that's jan tomorrow that's
when the UK formally leaves the EU you
don't think the Chancellor should act
now
on the NHS and the NHS I think you got
to wait for that money to accrue before
we start spending money we don't have
that's Labour's you know original sin if
you if you like but don't think on that
one minute we need to we need to read it
right dominator a flemish and we're snap
to be the country's gone for
the very polarized split to three to one
in favor of make according to you gov
this week to the extent we can transpose
at all making it work so what we should
do is not repeat and reheat the
referendum debate lockhorns
work together yes mitigate the risk but
also seize the opportunity decisions
taken Joe Graham and that's what say
that's all what it is but people like
dominate need to deliver on their
promises if they say they're going to
put 350 million pounds a week into the
NHS which they ordered then they should
deliver it but also look we are in
turbulent economic conditions here I
think you can't just leave the Bank of
England to do all this work you do need
fiscal policy to operate so I think the
Chancellor should consider cutting v80
to boost demand in the medium term
because we've got choppy waters ahead it
should improve investment in innovation
this is in basically in these three tiny
cutting social otherwise they we're not
going to deal strong economy in the g7
we're going to continue this reputation
when we've got our figures on Wednesday
budget sure you'll be in all this d-day